[Music]
what's up guys I am just from games but
here with her see from a Nintendo and we
are at Nintendo's e3 2018 boot here to
give you a look around so stick with us
and we'll show you what there is to say
it's very exciting we have a floor show
Alex so everything's laid out for us
we're gonna have a look around and right
now we're in front of the pokemon left
here pick a cheer and pokemon let's go
Eevee move to games that have just been
announced they look really cool tell me
about it
so we're super excited to be able to
bring Pokemon let's go Pikachu and
Pokemon let's go Eevee to the e3 show
floor so fans and players can come and
get hands-on with these new Procol and
experiences on Nintendo's switch with
partner pokemon so this is super
exciting you of course get Pikachu or
Eevee depending on the game Plus fans
who are getting to play using the
pokeball Plus which is the new little
accessory where you can use it in lieu
of a joy Kon to interact with the game
and you can actually carry a partner
Pokemon in the Polka ball or carry a
Pokemon in the pokeball and you can hear
them talk and we'll engage them and it's
super exciting sounds very cool well
there's heaps to see so let's see what
else we've got
we are here at the Mario Tennis AIDS
group before the show has even kicked
off so no the screens are on but we've
got a sneak peek for you anyway a game
looks really exciting and it's out
release it that's correct is coming out
on June 22nd brand new March and this
game for Nintendo switch super excited
the plays that to come in and get some
hands-on and learn that deep strategic
tennis gameplay you've got from the lobs
you gotta learn the slices and we're
standing on a tennis court so you just
get so excited to play awesome we're
down here at the third party section of
the Nintendo booth before the show opens
and there's a ton of different inks even
get hands-on with some of which worthy
just announced titles from the last few
days but walk us through what you've got
well it is super exciting that some of
these titles were only announced on
Tuesday morning are now playable on the
boots so fans can get hands-on with how
they play on Nintendo's switch I mean
we've got fortnight which is out now on
Nintendo eShop super exciting FIFA 19
Dragon Ball fighters once
generations ultimate just so many
different kinds of games that they can
try on Nintendo search
[Music]
all right now this is looking really
epic let me know where we're at at the
moment okay so this is an area dedicated
to Super Smash Brothers ultimate just
because I knew Super Smash Brothers
title for Nintendo switch we've detailed
here at e3 but this particular area is
dedicated to look like a battle stage
because this is the full glory section
where players are competing against each
other in a tournament star format and an
overall winner will be crowned we are
almost there the shows about to open in
just a matter of minutes but we're not
done looking at the Nintendo booth of
where are we now so we are still in the
Super Smash Brothers ultimate area but
this is the fourth fun section so people
are just coming in getting hands-on with
the title against other players and
competing in fun matches
[Music]
that is it the show has now started sir
we'd better be on our way by cookie
thank you so much for showing us around
and we hope you guys enjoy it to us
what's your find coming to play
[Music]